a week into the invasion of ukraine the
price of oil has soared at one point on
wednesday climbing to over a hundred and
thirteen dollars a barrel
analysts now say it could hit 125
dollars soon the fear and perception of
shortage or extra or excess oil always
affects the market the price immediately
this week the u.s and 30 allies pledged
to release 60 million barrels of oil
from the strategic reserves but the
world consumes about 100 million barrels
a day so the move has done little to
slow prices
if the united states was to end all
russian oil imports it would mean the
price that consumers pay at the pump
would go up a lot
but nevertheless there's growing calls
in congress for president joe biden to
do exactly that
end america's reliance on russian oil
on wednesday biden was asked about that
option nothing is off the table western
oil companies such as exxon shell and bp
are pulling out of russia exxon ending
operations and a four billion dollar
investment at a russian oil and gas
facility
shell cancelling a 3 billion joint
venture with russia's gas prom
all this after bp announced it would
pull out of a 19 stake in russia oil
company rosnef a deal valued at 14
billion dollars
analysts say the organization of
oil-producing countries known as opec
could have done more to prevent the
current crisis one of the key reason why
we are in this supply
in this very tight supply condition has
been opec unwillingness or
inability or most likely combination of
two to deliver
the supply that they promise month by
month this is a dramatic moment for
world oil supply and likely the market
won't stabilize until the uncertainty of
war ends
gabriel lozando al jazeera new york